est-ce que ça vous fait rêver ça ou
est-ce que vous dites franchement moi je
suis pas comme un fou d'avoir 187
milliards euh oui ça fait rêver en plus
c'est des succès au-delà de l'argent
mais je te parle de l'oseille bien sûr
succès tu fais ce que tu veux avec ça
mais avec avec tout ce que tu veux
beaucoup de avec beaucoup tu peux
dépenser ce que tu veux quand tu veux
dire tu peux faire des fondations pour
aider c'est génial quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
87 milliards de dollars si tu les
utilises pas évidemment tu as de la
suffisamment pour toi de ta famille tes
enfants
on coupe les caméras Bédard
un de bateau de 800 mètres le
plus gros bateau
la plus belle baraque du Sud une baraque
aux États-Unis une baraque par pays
pensé tu passes pas là
évidemment déjà moi l'avion ça m'emmerde
elle est partie
chaussures ton rêve ce serait d'avoir
combien moi job c'est un jet privé non
non mais d'abord combien d'argent ah
combien d'argent au monde ça serait
d'avoir ouais 100 millions d'euros c'est
bien ça serait ton rêve réaliser
10 millions d'euros des millions d'euros
d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s
franchement en toute honnêteté
vous me donnez maintenant un million je
suis très heureuse
[Rires]
arrête de penser à l'argent va
faire
l'argent
tu sors de dépression
surtout je pense que tu peux arrêter de
travailler si tu es malin tu peux te
faire C3 4000 € par mois tranquillement
pendant 30 ans
les deux je trouve que vous allez bien
ensemble
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est juste des gens simples
oui mais si on te dit ton rêve bah mon
rêve c'est pas d'avoir 3000 balles par
mois si c'est un rêve
qu'on avait un rêve au niveau de
l'argent déjà mais non mais il nous
demande la question
s'il te plaît
l'argent et arrête de de dehors
ah bah c'est sûr franchement c'est vrai
toi si tu t'en foutais pas de l'argent
tu seras avec moi
[Rires]
40 à 50 millions
toi justement je voulais vous en
parlerons une maison à ma maman une
maison pour moi je mets à l'abri toute
les enfants la famille tout ça déjà
belle condition et puis après je passe
un peu le reste je sais pas mais je vous
demanderai conseil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est bien mais vous avez des
beaux rêves bravo à vous et vous Cyril
pas du tout moi un million je suis très
heureux
[Rires]
imaginez vous avez un milliard pour
autant vous continuez l'émission
bonjour que c'est vrai que je sois là ou
pas je gagne pareil
je voulais dire c'est vrai je viens
vraiment parce que je kiffe venir ici je
vous jure que je kiffe venir et que je
vienne ou pas ça ne change pas à ce que
je gagne dans la vie et je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'est voilà c'est ça ne
change rien limite je vous jure que
c'est vrai je gagnerai plus d'argent si
je venais pas ah je ne Charris pas si je
produisais seulement l'émission
et je vous jure que c'est vrai que et
Benaim le sait c'est vrai que je voilà
donc
au contraire moi je viens pour kiffer
franchement je vous dire que c'est vrai
c'est mon kiff si je venais pour
l'argent frère et alors je vous dis on
vous manquerait alors et je vous le dis
c'est eux qui font alors et là c'est un
conseil que je vous donne à tous ceux
qui veulent faire ceux qui veulent faire
de la télé pour l'argent il va te faire
un truc pour de l'argent je vous le dis
c'est le meilleur moyen de se planter
voilà c'est c'est vrai regarde toi
on va passer quand même un coup d'oeil
devant sa maison quand même
c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai les mecs qui disent
ouais je veux faire de la je veux faire
ça parce que je veux faire de l'argent
je t'explique ils sont morts l'argent
est une conséquence c'est un objectif
bravo je sais pas ce que tu as dit mais
j'ai compris